- People have been queer
since the beginning of time.
- Yes, of course.
- Exactly, they have, and
no one's denying that.
- And people have acted upon that.
There's poetry, there's
erotic homosexual poetry.
- That's a sin.
If you look at every other religion,
that's a sin in every religion.
- No, it's not.
(dramatic music)
- [Producer] Step forward if
you agree with the prompt.
A good Muslim woman wears a hijab.
- First thing I wanna make clear
is that a Muslim woman who
doesn't wear the hijab,
that doesn't mean that
she's not a good Muslim.
The reason that I stepped forward
is because that means that this woman
has taken on the challenge
of going out every single
day wearing a head scarf
and wearing the proper clothing.
When they go outside wearing the hijab,
everyone that looks at them
knows they're a Muslim.
It's an extremely difficult
task that neither me or you
will ever understand,
but I have an extreme amount of respect
for any woman who wears a hijab properly.
- Yeah, of course. I agree with you 100%.
I look to the "Quran", which is our book,
and the son of the Prophet,
which is like the way the
Prophet lived, peace be upon him,
and what does it say about the hijab?
Hijab is something
that's ordained for women
in the "Quran".
- [Producer] Can the
disagreers step forward?
- So I think that one of the
main reasons why I disagreed
is because of the statement
"A good Muslim woman."
I think that you can be a
bad Muslim woman as well
and wear the hijab.
And then also, the hijab
is not just limited to the headscarf.
It's how you dress and how
you carry yourself as well.
- So actually I have a
question for both of you then.
Let's say you meet a Muslim woman,
and you marry her, she's wearing a hijab,
but one day she says like,
"Hey, maybe I don't wanna
wear hijab anymore."
I guess, where would your
thoughts to be on that
on her decision for doing that?
- It's about finding out why
they were wearing the hijab
in the first place.
Was it forced upon them by their parents
or was this something that they came
to the conclusion themselves that,
oh, you know what, I believe in Islam
and I believe what it said in the "Quran"
about wearing the hijab.
- Where do you see in the
"Quran" that it requires hijab?
- So Allah Subhanahu Wa Ta'ala
says (speaking foreign language).
So, here the word (speaking
foreign language),
it doesn't use the exact word hijab,
but the word (speaks in foreign
language) means headscarf.
- Yeah, that makes sense.
I guess for me in how
I've read the "Quran"
and the translation that I
have, the word isn't required
that women should cover their heads
and cover their chests.
And so that's why I hesitate
with saying that it's an obligation
because it's more of, I
would say, should isn't must.
- So personally, I guess I just took
the prompt too literally.
I mean, I consider myself
a good Muslim (speaks foreign language)
but I don't wear the hijab obviously.
Even if the "Quran"
doesn't specifically say
that this is required, the
interpretation of the "Quran"
has said that it is required
and I do believe that.
I know it seems kind of contradicting
that I'm a conservative Muslim
and I don't wear the hijab.
I don't think I'm ready to
kind of wear the hijab yet.
I want to wear the hijab.
I need to wear the hijab.
- [Producer] Acting on
homosexuality is a sin.
- I believe that acting
on homosexuality is a sin
especially if you were
expressing sexual desire
because that should take place
between a man and a woman
under the sanction of marriage.
So that is the reason why I
do feel as though it is a sin.
- And it's pretty clear in the "Quran"
and (speaking foreign language)
says (speaking foreign language).
If you guys prefer men over women,
where's he's talking to the people of Lut,
and Prophet, peace be upon
him, (speaks foreign language).
He says that one of the
biggest problems for the Ummah
is the sin of the people of Lut.
- Again, we can just all agree.
This is not our personal
opinion or anything,
and end of day, when it comes to religion,
our personal opinion
doesn't matter, right?
- [Participant] It does matter.
- [Participant] Doesn't matter,
this is what God ordained for us.
This is the natural way of humans.
Once we start diving in and
wanting whatever we want,
where does it end at that point?
Is it gonna come to incest next?
For instance, in America or in the West,
homosexuality 30 years
ago wasn't accepted,
or 40, 50 years ago,
but now it's acceptable.
This is the liberal idea, right?
The subjective morality, it
just shifts based on the time.
We don't shift in our religion.
My question for liberal Muslims would be,
who dictates objective morality?
Islam as God tells us in the "Quran"
is a religion in the middle.
So it has some aspects that
you have to believe in from God
and some things that are a
little bit more leeway for you.
We have to understand
which ones are which.
(instrumental music)
- May I start?
Yeah, I don't believe that
acting on homosexuality
is a sin at all.
There's so much to get into.
And the story of Profhilo itself,
you see that they weren't condemned
because the people of Profhilo were coming
to his house to have sex with the men
who were disguised as angels,
but you can look at it
as a condemnation of rape
and abuse itself and
mistreatment of strangers.
And the verse that you cited as well,
within that verse, Allah
uses the prefix, al,
which means the,
and there's interpretations
that exist that specifically
is talking about those men specifically
who leave those women specifically.
So meaning that those men
who did that had wives
that they left to go rape
these or try to attempt
to rape these guests in an
attempt to bring humiliation
upon the prophet and to,
sorry, I'm getting a little emotional.
Basically there's different
interpretations of the story
of prophet Lut.
One interpretation is that
it's about homosexuality
and there are other
interpretations throughout history
that says it wasn't about homosexuality,
but for some reason, the interpretation
that it is condemning homosexuality
is the dominant narrative.
And I think that narrative seriously needs
to be contended with because we're saying
that being homosexual or being bisexual
or being anything other
than heterosexual is a sin.
But Allah creates you like that.
Allah creates people who are intersex.
Intersex people exist in this world.
And so, I think there's a lot
of different interpretations
out there about the story of prophet Lut
and I think the central
point in it is contending
with the fact that people
use sex as a weapon,
a weapon for domination,
a weapon for humiliation.
That's a real issue.
And being homosexual,
being something that you
are naturally created isn't.
My experience being a queer
Muslim woman in America
has been beautiful.
Hamdulilah.
I've met and have been a part
of a beautiful Muslim community.
That is a mix of queer Muslims and not.
I don't think I've ever
experienced backlash at least
to my face for being queer and Muslim.
Mostly questions or curiosity.
But it hasn't ever been anything
that felt like hurtful or unsafe.
- So there's a couple
different points that you said
that I want to rebuttal and response to.
So the first one being that
you said being homosexual,
being bisexual, all those things is a sin?
First of all, that's incorrect.
Being any of those things
in itself is not a sin.
So that's why when the prompt
is acting on homosexuality,
that is the sin.
And Allah Subhanahu Wa Ta'ala says,
(speaking foreign language).
He does not burden the soul
with anything more than it can take.
As a Muslim you believe
that, like you just said,
Allah Subhanahu Wa Ta'ala created us all
and he created homosexual people,
those people with those
tendencies for a reason.
But at the same time,
this whole life is a test, right?
- Yep.
- And for the person who
has those tendencies,
then that's an extremely difficult test
that they're gonna have to go on with
for the rest of their lives.
And-
- But that's your assumption
that that is the only test.
What if the test is living
in a world that hates you,
that thinks that you cannot
act on a desire of love,
of consensual love, but still
being committed to Allah?
What if that's the test itself?
- That's part of that-
- And that's what I think is the test.
- Yeah, and that's, I would say, that's-
- And that's the interpretation out there
that we're not talking about.
- I have a question. Also.
- I'm sorry, I would
just also like to add,
the "Quran" also kind of
is about the nature, right?
The nature of life,
and so, acting upon homosexuality
goes against the nature
of why we were born.
Yeah.
And so, we were kind of like made in order
to procreate, right?
We need to-
- [Participant] But there's people
who can't procreate though.
- [Lemia] That's the way of life.
- But I would disagree that the purpose
of being with someone is to procreate
because in the "Quran" the law says
that Allah creates mates for us
so that we can find love,
tranquility and peace.
And I think a lot of the reason
why a lot of people think
that acting upon homosexuality is a sin
is because of Hadith.
And in those small numbers of Hadith
that are unambiguously correct,
there is no mention of
homosexuality in those Hadith.
Read "Homosexuality in Islam"
by Dr. Siraj Al-Haqq Kugle.
He talks about this extensively.
Keisha Ali also talks about this.
These are both two contemporary
scholars talking about this.
- These are minority
scholars in the way that,
why is this only?
- And that's fine.
- Yeah, no.
Why is this an issue only now
but not in all of this time of Islam?
- It has always been an issue.
- No. For sure, it hasn't.
The climate we're live in
nowadays, the liberal mindset-
- People have been queer
since the beginning of time.
- Exactly they have,
that's what I'm saying.
No one's denying that.
- And people have acted upon that.
There's poetry, there's
erotic homosexual poetry.
- And that's a sin.
If you look at every other religion,
that's a sin in every religion.
- No, it's not.
- Actually, it is.
- It's not up to me for
to interpret. That's what-
- Of course it is, then
what are we supposed to do?
- You look up to the
people with knowledge,
you look up to the people who
have dedicated their lives
to interpreting this in past 1400 years.
- You could do the same thing.
- I have, that's what I'm saying.
You can't ignore all the
scholars of the 1400 years.
- I'm not ignoring them.
But you can't just say
they're the only ones
who are correct.
I just told you two contemporary scholars.
- Two.
Two compared to thousands.
- And there's way more who
are also thinking about this.
- [Director] Yeah. Sorry,
I really appreciate.
I know that you are all very
passionate about this topic,
but I think there's no not
gonna be a middle ground,
which is okay.
I think the point is just
to still have a conversation
and I appreciate that you
guys are still listening
to each other and talking,
but we have to move on to the next prompt.
(air whooshes)
- [Producer] The other side
taints the image of Islam.
- I think that the
reason why I step forward
is because I feel like a
lot of conservative Muslims
as a Muslim revert have very
strong cultural beliefs.
That can be very intimidating
for somebody who is new to the religion
and it kind of discounts like
who I am and my own dean.
So that's why I think that
I feel that way just because
of the interactions that
I've had with born Muslims.
- Yeah, I love that point
because for me personally,
people who revert, we say revert obviously
because we believe that
every person is born Muslim,
but then they get changed their creed
by their parents, right?
People nowadays they have
some weird thing like,
oh, if I was born Muslim, I'm like,
they think they're better
and they treat them rudely
and this is not the
way of a Muslim, right?
The Muslim, we accept everyone
as they come to the religion.
- I was originally born into Christianity
and then I went on to college
to study religious studies
and at that time is whenever
I found peace with Islam.
And so I decided to revert.
I think the reason why I consider myself
to be a liberal Muslim versus conservative
is because I am a revert,
and I know that I have
so much more to learn
and I'm open to that.
I also believe that within
Islam, you have free will
and free choice to make
the correct decision.
And so I find a lot of
compassion for people in that way
because I did live life for
many years before Islam.
- People are so worried
about cancel culture.
People are so worried about
what everyone else thinks.
being accepted by society,
but who cares?
As a Muslim, it's our responsibility
to only care about the laws
Allah Subhanahu Wa Ta'ala thinks
and not care about what
anyone else thinks.
- Okay, so I guess why I
disagreed with the prompt
is because I feel Islam
is way stronger to be kind
of tainted by a group within it.
I may not agree with everything
that liberal Muslims think
or view but that doesn't
mean I feel like they
are like this big negative thing on Islam
because I just don't feel like
Islam can be affected by it.
- Yeah, and I agree that in
the fact that Islam itself
can't be.
The reason I agreed is because
the perception of Islam,
I feel like that's what's being affected.
- I disagree with that. I
don't think that's true.
I don't think having those
different ideologies really taint
either side because it's
not like someone gonna see,
and I'd agree for example,
you might not agree with this,
but I support gay rights,
right, and I'm Muslim.
And no one's looking at me and be like,
oh, now all Muslims support gay rights.
I'm like, no, it's not true.
It's just my personal preference
and that's why I kind of
disagree with both of you, guys.
If you guys say personal opinion
doesn't matter in religion,
I feel like it does at the end of the day
because religion is about who you are too.
- Personal opinion is okay
until it goes against what
Allah Subhanahu Wa Ta'ala said
or what the prophet peace
be upon him (speaking foreign language).
And no one's saying your
opinion doesn't matter.
Everybody's opinion matters.
But in relation to Islam,
your opinion isn't
gonna change the ruling.
You know what I'm saying?
- I agree with that, yeah.
- But the ruling itself
comes from people's opinions.
You realize that, right?
Jurist, that is what you do with the law.
You interpret the law and
you make a ruling from it
based on that.
- It's important to note that
people who kind of interpreted
the "Quran", like you're saying,
they're not just like normal
people like me and you.
- But they are.
- No, they are,
but those are like scholars
who kind of, like you said,
dedicated their life to kind
of studying the "Quran".
- Of Course.
And I think those people
are also biased like everyone, right?
Like everyone has their-
- I don't think in the case of
"Quran" that can be possible.
- It is possible 'cause we're humans.
All humans are biased and subjective
because the fact that we're human,
we have a different experience.
I'm gonna interpret something
or look at something completely different
than another human being is
because that's the nature
of our existence.
It's subjective.
- Just to make it clear,
this religion is done.
It has been perfected as
Allah tells us in the "Quran".
It's not like these
scholars are just coming in
and changing something new.
This is something that
we get it from a source.
We always have to go to the higher truth.
The higher truth is the prophet
and what the companions learned
from the prophet, right?
Because if we're just gonna go then,
yes, exactly your point,
because humans are subjective
on that bias, right?
But we get it from the best source,
which is our prophet, right?
If we don't follow the prophet,
who are we gonna follow?
- "It's acceptable for a Muslim man
to have more than one wife."
- I guess for me, I think
monogamy is not for everyone.
And so I think Muslim men, Muslim women
can have more than one
partner if it's consensual.
- Allah tells us in "Quran"
that you can marry up to up to four.
But the precaution is that you
maintain equity between them.
And if you can't, then
you have to stick to one.
You mentioned that men and women.
This is the difference, right?
Because only men in this way.
A man can marry up to four
because think of this situation,
say for instance he
had more than one wife,
say for instance four wives, right?
And he gets one of them pregnant, right?
Everyone's gonna know who the husband is
and who the father is.
If a woman has more than one husband,
someone gets her pregnant,
no one's gonna know
who the father is.
That's not the exact reason,
but I'm saying just an example,
just to think about it.
And in the end of the day is
because Allah tells a story.
- We live in a vastly different time.
We view women differently in this world.
Just because that is what the
"Quran" said in that context
doesn't mean that we can't
interpret differently now.
- Okay, maybe I'm the old fashioned one
because I always believe love is,
I mean, I believe marriage is
always like a love marriage.
I don't think you can love
four people at the same time.
That's just my personal opinion.
If you do get married,
get married to the person
that you wanna be with
for the rest of your life
and the person you know
you share love with,
not someone you just get
married because you have
the authority to marry up to four people.
- You could have a love marriage,
but you can also have an
institution of marriage
and I also think that that's what Islam
kind of bases marriage
around as well, right?
Because even the model modeled
after the prophet piece began
to him, when it came to
him having four wives,
it was based off of actually
like merging tribes together,
political reasons and
also someone was a widow.
So with that being said, I
think that it's just different
and I think that that's one of the topics
that we kind of have to
seek the wisdom behind
before we just make it
about like today's times.
- Yeah. Can men marry four women? Yes.
But you can't.
I mean you, can't be-
- Unjust.
- Yeah, you can't be just
with all the four of them.
- The four wives have to agree to it too.
- [Participant] Exactly.
If you wanna marry someone
else, a lot of women themselves
don't even want.
They're not okay with that.
- So, yeah, you can do it,
but you'll never be able
to do it the right way,
so don't do it.
- [Producer] Christianity
deserves the same scrutiny
as Islam.
- Yeah, I think that
Islam is very scrutinized
in Western media specifically
for their practices
because if you are
following the word by text,
a lot of it doesn't align
with what Western values hold.
Islam has always been a target for people
on the Western side,
people around the world.
And I think Christianity
has always been seen
as kind of just like this
top of the level religion.
It's like, you're a Christian,
you're a good person,
you can't do no wrong.
- Yeah. I think all
religions need scrutiny.
I think any religion can
be taken to extremes.
You can not understand certain things
and go do things that
are harmful to others.
In terms of Christian history,
you had the crusades and Islamic history,
you also had colonialism as well.
So, yeah, every religion
needs to be scrutinized.
We can't just follow blindly.
- Yeah, I think the question
was hard for me to answer
'cause I don't believe
that any religion really needs scrutiny.
I think that for me as a born Christian,
I can understand why
Christianity and Islam
are kind of like looked
at kind of differently
just based on rituals and the
way that it's expressed out
into the world.
But I guess the question
kind of just caught me up
with the scrutiny part.
What exactly are we scrutinizing and why?
- I agree there shouldn't be
any scrutiny on any religion.
And why do I say this?
Because Allah tells us in the "Quran".
When he would give the revelation
to the prophet Muhammad,
peace be upon him,
because who were the people in Mecca?
They were pagans, right?
He told them, don't attack their gods,
don't say anything bad to their gods.
God tells us when we're talking
to (speaking in foreign language),
meaning, the people of the book,
the Christians and the Jews,
we speak in a nice way.
- Yeah.
I just don't like how Islam
gets treated worldwide
in the modern sense.
I think we're always like perceived as-
- The bad guy.
It's always us.
It's always, attack this
Islam did or you live
in Islamic country's
violence, stuff like that.
So I definitely think it's
unfair how we're always like
the scapegoat for religions.
I grew up in a more dominant
white suburb in Illinois.
I suffered heavy racism
every day in middle school
and elementary school.
The original remarks, terrorist,
go back to your country,
all that stuff.
Growing up as a kid, I was religious.
But then as I got to
high school and college
and started forming my own thoughts,
I kind of went away from Islam.
I kind of explored other things.
But then the last three to four years,
I started reading more about Islam.
I started practicing
more because I finally
had my own freedom to actually practice it
and not have my dad and my parents like,
oh, you have to do this,
you have to do that.
So I definitely felt more
comfortable practicing on my own.
- [Producer] The "Quran"
must be reintegrated
for the 21st century.
- Well, I feel like this
is kind of like the crux
of what I've been saying this whole time.
You always need to
reinterpret the "Quran".
Whoever's looking at the "Quran"
and whoever's reading it
needs to interpret it,
needs to understand what
Allah's telling that person.
All the information,
everything that we're learning
is about getting us
closer to a just future.
And in the time of the prophet,
slavery was well and alive
The "Quran" never outright
abolished slavery.
But people through their interpretation
decided that the "Quran" is leading us
to a future where slavery
shouldn't be allowed
because it's unjust.
- Yeah, I agree.
I think the "Quran" or the text
is a holy text that
should never be changed
or obviously re-written.
That's off the table.
But I think interpretation
kinda like we talked
about the whole time matters.
But I've consulted with
different mosque leaders,
different people who actually study Islam
and not once there was like a big overlap
'cause they have their own interpretation
of what the "Quran" is
into the modern world.
So I just think in general,
there definitely should be a
more modern interpretation.
(instrumental music)
- The first thing is,
so we as Muslims believe
that obviously that the
"Quran" is the word of God
and no one is disagreeing with the fact
that society has changed.
Do you believe that Allah
knows the seen and the unseen?
- Yes.
Okay, so when Allah Subhanahu Wa Ta'ala
revealed the "Quran", Allah
Subhanahu Wa Ta'ala knew what
was gonna happen in the future
and he knew what was
gonna happen to society.
And when revealing the "Quran",
the "Quran" is timeless.
Any reinterpretation of the
"Quran", I believe is incorrect
because then what would differ
the "Quran" from the "Bible"?
- So, should slavery still be a thing?
- No, but...
Go ahead.
- Okay. The slavery is
a whole nother topic.
Slavery in the time of the
prophet was not the same
as the trends, whatever-
- Just the act of owning
another human being.
- That's a whole nother thing.
They were basically just a servant.
They could buy their own freedom.
They had rights. They weren't
treated like an animal
as we see in our history
in America how it was.
This is not what it was.
Going back to the actual prompt,
the "Quran" is (speaking
in foreign language)
in the people.
It's a mercy for the humans
Allah gave us to, right?
The "Quran" is the words
of Allah, right, of God.
- In the simplest form, I
just believe that the "Quran"
is like a sacred text.
And sacred text as a whole
just should not be touched.
When I think about
reinterpretations, I almost think
about like amendments in a way.
If we believe that the
prophet, peace be unto him,
is the last and final messenger,
then whatever was revealed
to him, it is that.
- You can't reinterpret everything
'cause the second you open up one thing
for reinterpretation, you're
opening up the whole religion
for reinterpretation.
- It's not opening up the whole religion.
The religion itself is
devotion to Allah alone.
That is what Allah says in
(speaking in foreign language)
that Islam equals devotion to Allah alone.
- Of course.
It was awesome speaking to you, guys.
- Yeah, that's great.
- Thank you.
(upbeat music)